You might use the word
abstract when someone's making
ambiguous statements or to
refer to groups of things you lumped
together or to talk about things you can't
pin down to a single
object in space and time.
Research papers have abstracts.
Art can be abstract and we can
engage in abstract thinking,
but what is it about something
that makes it abstract?
Give me a pattern. Here's
one. Orange basketball, we'll,
what's the pattern here? Well,
when you compare them side by side,
you get this idea of round
just by focusing on this shape,
we can abstract this shape from these
three objects in the world around us.
Of course, if you're more of a top
down guy like Plato was, I get that.
You start with the idea of round and you
can go out and find instances of realm
things, wheels, balls and oranges.
It was comparing things in our world
that made us stop and think about the
abstract concept round.
That kind of comparison is a huge
step when that gets us humans.
We're really far,
but that's not quite enough.
Let's look a little closer at the steps
we took to get to that abstract notion
round.
I mean looking at this object alone,
we could have easily ended up abstracting
wheel or spokes or tire or something
else. When we place it
next to the other objects,
we compare them to see
their common features,
but that's still not enough.
Think about it.
We have a list of specific features each
object has and one of them on each list
happens to be shared, but if we take
away the details of each object,
we get to the abstraction
in the 1960s to know region.
Computer scientists recognize the
technological power of abstractions.
They introduced classes which allowed
programmers to define abstract concepts
like say us fear and objects,
which let programmers create
specific instances of that class,
like a golf ball or a globe.
They used abstraction to give birth to
object oriented programming and there are
many more examples of the
technological power of abstractions,
but abstract thinking isn't just
the stuff of new technology.
It's something we do every
day with language and thought.
Even though,
say every cat is different,
we can have just a word
for the abstract cat,
same four person.
We can set up conceptual hierarchies.
We can even abstract numbers away to
a simple variable that can take on any
value we need it to. This kind
of thing is extremely convenient.
What's even better is that if
we just go one step further,
abstractions become even more powerful
and we'll take that step next time.